eminent domain allowed the city of New
London Connecticut to seize a private
owners land and house eminent domain is
an absolute necessity for a country for
our country
we shouldn't have to give up her
property so somebody else can make money
off it
my name is Suzette kilo I live in New
London Connecticut and I am kilo and the
kilo versus the city of New London
seventeen years ago Suzette kilo was a
registered nurse living in a pink house
in a sleepy New England town she would
go on to fight a historic battle against
the city of New London Connecticut for
trying to seize her property today Kela
story is more relevant than ever in the
late 90s kilo bought her Dream Home
a little slice of heaven on the water
the best house she could find for her
money
seven months after moving in though Hilo
was told she had to move out you see the
city of New London Connecticut had other
plans for Suzette kilos neighborhood a
new pharmaceutical research facility for
the Pfizer corporation
city officials said it would bring
business and jobs to the area and
started buying out homeowners I won't we
absolutely and look they dragged me off
by my ankles I'm not going many
homeowners didn't want to sell so the
city tried to use the power of eminent
domain to get their land the practice of
government taking private property with
what the government determines is fair
compensation kilo and six other
residents organized and sued on the
grounds that it was unconstitutional
after seven years the case reached the
Supreme Court but the court sided with
the city the ruling was fresh and very
unpopular but not too one infamous real
estate developer I happen to agree with
it a hundred percent I think overall if
the President of the United States
thinks this was a good decision then we
should all be shaking in our boots a
little bit that's Courtney Bala Kerr and
she's the writer and director of a new
film called little pink house about
kilos fight to keep her home we started
this whole process of putting this film
together three years ago we had no idea
that Suzette's most famous opponent
would be the President of the United
States so it's a pretty mind-blowing and
it really is just sort of a coincidence
that we made this film and then he all
of a sudden got in the race I I think
people should be very concerned eminent
domain is an absolute necessity for a
country for our country I mean the
domain is consistent with Trump's
authoritarian approach to government
which
this issue more relevant than ever apart
from putting you in jail or killing you
to take away your home or your
livelihood is about the most serious
thing that the government can do Scot
Bullock was Suzette's attorney we caught
up with him at the film's sold-out
premiere at the Santa Barbara Film Fest
of all cities and developers cannot go
down this path again of taking and a
people's property and abusing the power
of eminent domain I think it's gonna
make a huge statement I really do not a
lot of people have the energy to do it
not a lot of people have the courage or
the principle and what struck me was
it's not like she was this retired woman
looking for her cause she was exhausted
and this was the last thing she wanted
to do but she did it anyway because it
was the right thing to do freaking out
it's always the only thing that protects
me from them that's Academy Award
nominated actress Catherine Keener is
kilo she really captured Suzette's
humility and aversion to the spotlight
and what resonated with her about this
story was this concept of your spot your
place when you find your place and you
can really root yourself into that place
and how disruptive that is to somebody
to uproot you against your will
[Music]
overwhelming it's surreal really actress
Jeanne Tripplehorn plays Charlotte Wells
who in the movie spearheads the
initiative to forcibly take kilos home
to build visors facilities that
character truly believed that what she
was doing was right and she gets a voice
in the films all the typical rationales
for ceasing private property namely
creating jobs economic revitalization
and restoring a sense of grandeur to a
fallen industrial town she had a great
way of describing it this is a very
misguided woman someone who was on the
right path but then went down the very
very wrong path to get what she wanted
you see the city didn't understand that
it's impossible to put a fair price in
another person's property which is a
major theme of the movie you know I
never noticed that locket it's beautiful
oh yeah thank you it was my
great-grandmother's yeah would you be
interested in selling it oh it's an
heirloom 500,000 mm okay what would it
take despite the disappointing outcome
of the 2005 Supreme Court case public
outrage over the issue led many states
to pass laws reining in eminent domain
abuse IJ made tremendous progress with
this case and a lot of those laws would
not have gone the right way if it hadn't
been for AIA - but there's still a lot
of work to be done
oh and Pfizer's new facility it was
never built after the city seized and
bulldozed many of the homes in the area
Pfizer walked away from the venture
today the site of the proposed project
is a wasteland
don't forget eminent domain they get a
lot of money and you need a house in a
certain location because you're going to
build this massive development that's
going to employ thousands of people or
you're going to build a factory that
without this little house you can't
build the factory
I think eminent domain is fine this is a
movie about insiders versus outsiders
and if you're on the inside then you
have the power but if you're on the
outside you don't
[Music]